[Music]
please say yes
[Music]
it's heaven
there you are more radiant than ever my
god
still spoiling her milton
i am in a position to help financially i
can look after us
don't be too proud
twins don't know just one beautiful boy
no
i had twins again i saw no name to me
she's not well we know she's not well
why are you looking at me like this
how are you feeling she hasn't had an
episode in three years she was off her
medication
how could you not know ross it's me
please call
what's going on where are they
hello she took the passport
and she took my son maybe out of the
country i'm gonna call the police
what can i do
have you seen this do you believe she
could hurt your son
i don't know we don't know the facts
i need to know how this happened you're
in a state of shock
you have to get a grip
where's mommy i've been followed
no more games you're not playing well
is that what you want locked up in a nap
house for the rest of your life
[Music]
[Music]
you